thanks for inviting me here to talk to
you guys and for the gracious
introduction so for i'll start the
session by just giving you
a background of southeast asia uh and
the startup ecosystem in particular i'm
not sure how many of you are familiar
with what's happening there so i'll i'll
spend uh half the time talking about
that
and then the other half talking about us
i'm the managing partner at tech grove
ventures we're a growth accelerator
and we'll share some experiences of what
we do in trying to help us companies
accelerate into southeast asia and vice
versa helping southeast asian companies
accelerate into the u.s
the reason why i'm using a picture of
the rainforest in southeast asia is
because it is a tropical place
but also because
you know the book the rainforest book
about you know silicon valley and
creation of the ecosystems
and uh although i would like to say that
southeast asia is at a stage where it's
like a rainforest in in having diversity
and having uncontrolled growth of
startups
it's not quite there yet it's more like
a plantation if you've
read the book in a plantation is where
governments come in and they plant trees
and crops and they they decide you know
who's early stage and who's growth stage
and they hope that they can architect
the ecosystem and create at the end of
the rainforest but it's not quite there
yet hopefully it will get there
soon
so
let me just start with a primer on
southeast asia so what i mean are the 10
companies that comprise what we call
asean association of southeast asian
nations
the biggest ones are indonesia with
about 260 million people
second largest is the philippines with
about 95 million
malaysia thailand follows that and then
they have smaller countries like laos
myanmar
cambodia and
and brunei but these represents a
grouping of countries that are different
from china of course different from
india and bangladesh and of course
different from the rest of north asia
korea and japan
collectively as richard has mentioned
the population is 617 million uh it
represents nine percent of global
population
uh it's uh as a grouping it is number
three behind india and china and much
larger than the us
its foreign direct investment per capita
is about 150
that is actually on par with china
which has doubled the population of 1.2
billion people and several times that
per capita compared to india so there's
a lot of foreign direct investment
that's going in there and that sort of
is because of the growth potential that
richard was talking about earlier
there's a growing middle class there are
about 55 million
middle class households and growing
199 million online users
and mobile is huge right almost 700
million mobile users more than 100
percent
uh penetration that means they're more
phones per person more than one phone
per person
and very social group
over
72 percent of people are on some kind of
a social network a lot of it is facebook
twitter
uh they're not banned in southeast asia
for the most part
uh and so there's very very large usage
of social networks
so this creates uh really a really large
green field opportunity that is really
developing very very quickly
this is a bit of an eye chart but let me
walk you through it a lot of people say
well so what does that mean in terms of
startup opportunities so
this is a map and i'll go through the
map just i'll just highlight some of the
findings right it's a map of startup
opportunities by country by market
segment so on the left you have market
segments like
deal sites uh
like messagings messaging apps
search capabilities
uh listings like craigslist blogging
sites so that's on the left and then
vertically there are six of the largest
countries
and basically the heat map shows how
saturated is that segment in that
country red is very saturated green is
basically
at infancy stage
so you can see that there are various
segments like deal sites groupon type
deals communications like messaging and
search like google and others saturated
across the region
right
but look at the rest of it it's largely
green
so when i say greenfield i mean it is
green across the top six countries in
the region
and across many many of the market
segments
so that's one one uh finding
the other finding is that um if you look
at the highlighted areas in boxes on the
red on the left
before i go into what they are they
represent oh by the way the the names
inside each blocks represents the top
player in that segment for that country
so for example
the top news site in the philippines is
rappler
which is a local player right
you know the top philippines deals
player is called metro deal which is
another local player
now what is evident is that if you look
at the highlighted boxes on the left
these are segments
where there are local players regional
players and global players all active
within that country
so new sites gaming sites online retail
rentals dining travel all of them are
very hot because every kind of player is
active in that country
a local player only a regional player
that perhaps is out of another country
and then of course a global player from
the us or europe
so it shows that these highlighted areas
are the most interesting they're the
hottest because every type of player is
playing in it right
so i would say in summary if you wanted
to understand
what the output opportunities are by
segment this is one place that you can
look at it but in general there's a lot
of green field opportunity
and there are still many segments which
where there are only local players
involved which means there's opportunity
for consolidation
typically that consolidation happens
when a global player like facebook or
groupon goes in and acquires these
players and then and gets a regional
foothold
clear are you comfortable with us
sharing this slide on our website or
will it be
no this is this we can use this so we'll
post the slides on
asia.stanford.edu so you'll be able to
see this in detail yeah i i obviously
don't have time to go through the
details but the idea is that there's a
lot of greenfield opportunity and this
this tells you where they are
there is a growing number of tech m a
exits
this is a report by one of the venture
firms there called monks hill ventures
which is a new player in the market
and over the last six years you see on
the top left number of acquisitions it
has been growing and last year in 2013
there were 24 acquisitions
first half of this year we're already at
16.
the transaction amounts have been
increasing if you look at the table in
the top right
the country which has had the most
companies being acquired has been
singapore uh over that period 32
companies have been acquired
total disclose acquisition amount is
half a billion dollars
the second to that i would say is
probably
malaysia
in terms of having the largest number of
disclose amount the largest total
disclose amount of the acquisition so it
has only 12 number of companies acquired
but it has the largest amount of total
amount of acquisition dollars
so you can see that there is a growing
m a path
these are just some examples of of some
of the recent m a in singapore there's a
company called non-stop games that was
acquired by candy crush
saga maker king in the uk
zopim acquired by zentaq in the us for
30 mil
vicky mo the most recent one acquired by
rakuten in japan for 200 million
and some other ones i would highlight uh
there are some in indonesia and then
malaysia are some of the biggest m a's
job street was acquired by sikh which is
an australian company for half a billion
dollars and then malaysia online is an
e-commerce player which just listed on
nasdaq able to raise 300 million dollars
so
in general
with some exceptions most of the m a's
have been below 100 million dollars so
certainly these are not large
deals
the second thing to note is that there
are growing number of acquirers that are
asian
from japan from korea right or from
australia they are the ones doing the
acquisitions rather than just the the
typical american companies so you're
seeing now that with the rise of asia
you now have larger countries larger
companies out of japan china korea that
are starting to acquire all these
smaller players in southeast asia
okay
so let me go into detail in two of the
largest and most developed startup
ecosystems the first is singapore and
the other is malaysia
a bit of an eye chart but i'll just walk
you through it so the singapore
ecosystem on one slide startups looks
like this
one big player and a key enabler to make
it happen is the government
very unlike the us where we basically
stay as far away as possible except when
we're asking them to open up a patent
office
but otherwise we want the government in
southeast asia if the government doesn't
step in basically the ecosystem cannot
cannot take off
so the key players in the singapore
government that make that that create
the startup ecosystem is
ida that's the infocom development
authority they're the agency that drives
it the it sector
nrf national research foundation so they
are the r d agency in singapore
uh spring which is the sme agency so
they're in charge of all small medium
enterprises once one segment of which is
tech startups
so they've been playing uh you know you
know a large role
they've actually built up a large and
growing list of investors
um if you look at um
a venture capital right um
they're they they they're trying to
attract many regional vcs and even us
vcs to open up office in singapore and
they do this by offering incentives
so either doing
co-matching investments on a deal-by-day
basis
or they actually set up funds on a on a
50 50 basis
so a lot of investors have actually been
attracted to to open up there so you
know this is a pretty long list of 30 or
so investors
some of the ones that have us
that come from the us are
just looking at this
myself
sequoia obviously and on the on the
large side but even in the smaller early
stage side you've got golden gate
ventures which is from the us
um
i'm missing one more but anyway there
are a couple of us ones that
have actually taken advantage of some of
these incentives and started opening up
shop in in singapore
so in general if you look at early stage
and growth stage venture capital
there is sufficient
early stage vc funds in singapore
which actually is not just for singapore
but of course they invest across the
region
however the growth stage meaning series
a and beyond there's still a lack of
funding
and sometimes the vcs complain that
there are not enough investable startups
that's the reason why there aren't more
growth stage funding available there but
if you talk to the startups that are at
growth stage just saying the vcs don't
understand the game right so it's always
the same same old same old the push pool
right
co-working spaces they're sprouting up
all over the place so certainly there's
a lot of physical communities now being
created in singapore startups are
flocking there not only from singapore
but from across the region because they
want to be co-working together with this
active community
generally if you're a singapore startup
you're targeting the regional market
or even the global market you're never
targeting the local market because
singapore is too small right so they
have to be global from day one
there are accelerators that are growing
accelerators are very interesting the
government offers accelerators uh 70
subsidy of their operating costs so if
you open up an accelerator in singapore
and you're selected to be a qualified
one 70 of your operating budget it gets
paid for by the government
on top of that if you run a program for
example
you run a three-month acceleration
program with mentorship you know office
space you you name it the government
could sponsor the cost of these
additional programs
so it's very attractive right they want
to get many many accelerators to uh you
know open up shop trying to complicate
the yc mod to copy the the yc model and
the techstars model in singapore some of
the us players that have taken advantage
of that are people like plug and play
and the foundry institute both of whom
are in singapore already for the last
couple of years
finally the bottom networking events
singapore has established itself as a
startup hub as far as events are
concerned so some of the largest
events for the region for startups are
happening in singapore and some of the
big players like demo here are already
doing their their uh show in in
singapore so before you go on i know we
said that we would do questions at the
end but yeah you mentioned that most of
the of the startup companies are aiming
at regional markets yes um
what percentage would you say you're
really trying to use singapore as a jump
off place for mainland china
or versus really looking at southeast
asia any idea or just
you know kind of impression
my impression is that uh if you wanted
to go into the china market you
shouldn't
you should be single you should be in
china okay and
at this day and age you should be in
china yeah maybe 10 years ago you would
have been in singapore yeah but those
days are gone
so the singapore startups are that act
of really looking at the southeast asia
markets well uh so conversely when you
respond when you ask the singapore
startup how would they want to grow
their business i will cover this a bit
later
typically as a singaporean startup or a
malaysian startup there are three
strategic options when you get growth
stage
you come here and you become an american
company and hopefully get a chance of
becoming global that's option one
but in that means you uproot the whole
company you basically become a us
company
second strategic option
is to expand into china because they
know that southeast asia is too
fragmented and if they were to choose
the next biggest market it would be
china and because there's some cultural
affinity but it's difficult to get into
china
third is just to stay a regional con
company and just try to expand into
indonesia expand into the philippines
and get to a large enough market share
that you will get acquired which is
which is already happening as you saw in
one of them
so these are the three strategic options
and i'll talk a little bit about some
experience i've had when i talked to
south singaporean or malaysian startups
when they come and say winston so which
one should we do
all right it's a difficult question
okay
uh some of the stars uh in
singapore startups
won't go through the details but in
general you see that most of the stars
are in e-commerce or in payment which
are two of the biggest and hottest
segments that you saw in the eye chart
that i mentioned earlier so this is just
because of the growth of the middle
class online access mobile access that
people are starting to want to buy stuff
and they want to buy stuff online just
like when what they did here 10 15 years
ago
so these are the biggest stars um
what have we done tech growth ventures
so
back in march we hosted
spring which is the government agency
driving
startups
they brought along two incubators from
singapore one is singapore management
university
who has their own incubator and then
iaxel which is another incubator and
they brought along eight startups
um so these eight startups are not your
typical early stage they already have
product they already have revenues they
are already regional
right but they've never been into the
u.s market
okay
so they are beyond an accelerator
program like what we typically would see
in a
yc or a tech stars or a 500 startups
they're beyond that they're beyond that
from a southeast asian standpoint
they've actually probably gone through
some of these accelerators in southeast
asia
what they want to do is come here and
look for
market entry because as i said this is
one of the strategic options for them
one example is quantine is a video
interviewing platform so what they do is
they build a database of job applicants
who do a video interview
right and they answer you know specific
questions
and they build this large database and
they offer that as a subscription to
employers that are looking to hire
people now with video
as a screen right before they bring them
in for a face-to-face
they are the leading uh video
interviewing platform in southeast asia
and they've only got one competitor in
the us
so some of these companies are very
innovative they're not just me too kind
of companies
now
the challenges these companies face so
what are they looking here when they say
u.s market entry they're looking for
customer development
they're looking for strategic partners
and of course they're looking for
funding to grow right
um
they're not here to look for education
they're not here to look for a yc type
program they're beyond that right
but they don't have the money to invest
and to grow into into china let alone
the u.s unless they get some investment
the challenges they face is that number
one
without any local presence without any
market traction
you're not going to get funding
right number two
the early stage
most of the accelerators here can't help
them because they just love the early
stage companies they don't want to talk
to somebody that is already growth stage
right
and you know it's a mismatch and the
other accelerators are mostly only
helping them with networking and in
funding pitch events they can't help
them with business development which is
what these guys need
um let me see whether there were any
other challenges i thought there was
another challenge that i saw that that
we've learned in working with some of
these companies
um
sorry
yeah and the third biggest uh challenge
is u.s investors don't understand
southeast asia
and some of them can't invest in
southeast asia even though they have a
an active fund just because their funds
are supposed to be u.s centric
so this is the challenge challenges that
they face and i said as i said before
for these types of growth stage
companies from singapore there are only
these three strategic options right they
usually retreat back to asia and either
expand into china or just stay within
southeast asia which i think is a missed
opportunity
uh now let me talk about malaysia in
detail as well
i'm from malaysia by the way
so there similarly the government has
played a very significant role
magic is an agency that is a sort of
one-stop shop for entrepreneurs which
just launched this year sme corp is very
similar it runs a small medium
enterprises in malaysia
mdec is the i.t agency
and cradle is an early stage grant
funding entity
so they've been playing a very
significant role in starting to build up
an ecosystem in malaysia
the venture capital for series a and
beyond the growth stage
capital has been mostly government
funded right there are very few
foreign vcs at the growth stage in
malaysia so math cap is the national
vc you know the money comes from the
government
first floor capital is also money coming
from the government and almost all the
other players that you see in the top
right hand box
are players that are local that have
money coming from the government so they
outsource their inv their vc funds to
some of these players they're very few
uh big big players outside of malaysia
and the early stage venture
is just very nascent right now
so catcher group just launched a fund
150 million us dollars their private
entity
but the rest of them 500 startups
actually runs a small
site fund called 500 durians fund i
don't know whether you know duran is a
fruit they come from southeast asia so
they call themselves 500 durians
part of that money comes from the
government but they basically focus on
on early stage and it is but they're
very you know this very nascent space
incubators and accelerators um you know
you've got
you know a handful of them 100 1337
accelerator mat incubator
and then there's some
u.s ones like bootstrap labs and foundry
institute that are also in malaysia now
so i would say that
in general the ecosystem in malaysia is
a lot smaller than singapore but the
government is putting a lot of effort in
trying to build it up
over time
so some of the stars in malaysia
i will you know this is just data from
march of last year
but if you look at
publicly listed companies in southeast
asia
that attack
uh six out of the top uh seven are
malaysian in terms of uh capitalization
so you can see that even though the num
the ecosystem is not as large for
startups in malaysia but some of the
biggest players in southeast asia
actually have been malaysian
i won't go into all the details but
if in summary the most
the sectors that are the hardest are job
job listings which is job street that
was the company that was acquired for
500 have a billion dollars
and then the rest of them are various
types of e-commerce sites
right so there's a lot of a lot of stars
in malaysia too even though the
ecosystem is is much less developed than
singapore
so can you uh explain the two columns of
of numbers
so
there's the the company
one is in ringgit and the other is u.s
dollars oh okay okay
yeah and then the the the second column
that's right
um
so what have we done as tech growth
ventures in malaysia three years ago
i actually partnered with mdec which is
the i.t agency of malaysia
and we brought a group of mentors from
silicon valley to go to malaysia to help
mentor about 35 startups
they are typically early stage startups
so we did uh you know hands-on
workshops with them and then when we
came back i organized a bunch of meetups
where i brought silicon valley
professionals to
together to listen to pitches from
selected uh malaysian companies over
skype
you know i just felt that there was a
need to try to
bridge some of the problems that i saw
earlier by matching these malaysian
companies with
co-founders here or partners here at the
early stage so that they can together
build a cross-border company
i believe that's the way to solve these
kinds of problems over time is how do
you create a cross-border company
cross-border means that you have a
co-founders that come from different
countries
right it means you're you know you're
registered in multiple countries and
therefore you you know you have market
presence you have a network that is
across border so that was my attempt at
trying to get that going
and then
more recently this year
as i said magic is the agency that's
been launched in april which is
basically a one-stop shop entrepreneur
agency their job is to create the
startup ecosystem and when they launched
in april obama was actually in malaysia
that was the second time a u.s president
has actually visited malaysia the
previous time was 40 plus years ago
and so it was coincidental he was there
he helped launched magic center
and there's actually an oval in front of
this huge building it's called the obama
oval
so next week actually there is a group
of 30 malaysian startups that is going
to be here at stanford
for a two-week immersion and networking
program so it's going to be taught by
two stanford professors
they're going to be here and tegra
ventures we are going to be hosting them
to talk about
lean u.s market entry how do you enter
the u.s market in a lean way right so
let us know if you're interested to meet
some of these startups because i think
it'll be good to
you know explore opportunities with them
so summarizing what are the asian
startup the southeast asian startup
trends one as i said is rapid regional
ecosystem development over the last
couple of years i would say only the
last three years it has been rapid and
is led by singapore
government are key enablers
it's very interesting
as i said to find out when governments
should step back
right when is the right time for them to
step back and already in singapore
you're starting to see some of these
tensions in terms of
when governments try to over engineer
the startup ecosystem there are some
unexpected effects
what that what that does
uh you also have situations where
startups and singapore says to hell with
it i'm not going to
go i'm not going to be over engineer
anymore i'm going to become an american
company and then the government starts
to panic it's owner we're losing our our
gems
right so it's a two-way it's a two-way
street
market fragmentation is a key challenge
it's sort of like europe where you've
got 10 countries culturally very
different
uh development-wise some difference
right malaysia and singapore are very
developed or not very more developed
and then you've got the biggest ones uh
philippines and indonesia are much less
developed so you've got different stages
of economic development cultural
differences as i said and of course the
way of doing business in these countries
are still very much built based on
relationships so if you wanted to sell
into let's say corporations in indonesia
or malaysia or in singapore
is a whole different way of entering the
market each and every time that you have
to restart
so challenge fragmentation is a problem
a growing number of exits as they've
seen a new wave of investors in summary
i would say the ecosystem is still not
sustainable
i'm curious
to find out later on from you guys which
ecosystem do you think is sustainable
outside of silicon valley i mean startup
ecosystem
well in in southeast asia it's still not
sustainable yet so there's still work
that needs to be done by the government
and by people like us to try to prop it
up
and the model for collaboration between
southeast asia startup ecosystem and the
us is still evolving there are only some
early players like us and others that
are trying to bridge these ecosystems
but what's the business model is that
business model sustainable it's still to
be seen
okay
so this is now to growth ventures right
right so this is us
so we're based in santa clara um and
our job is to basically to help as i
said u.s companies enter the southeast
asian market and vice versa
so here in the u.s we have a center step
set up
where we do workshops we do mentorship
we do seminars funding pitches and
others so
we select uh southeast asian companies
that we think have good potential good
technology decent teams all growth stage
well we don't look at companies that are
just early stage companies
and then we help them get into the us
market
and it's not just distribution right it
is all about finding co-founders if they
need it
finding funding when they're ready and
have traction
it is about finding strategic partners
that help them validate their business
so
uh in asia we have uh we have partners
where we have got a similar presence out
in asia you know overall our goal is
we're very business development oriented
we're not education we're not events
we're about helping them build a
business traction either in the u.s or
in malay in southeast asia
and over time we want to build a
portfolio of these companies that are
from the us or southeast asia where we
have equity that's our model
we're also raising a venture fund uh
we're in the process of doing that now
sorry go ahead are you adding any value
on the technical side of the
engineering side or is it mostly
customer development not fundraising not
as much on the technical side
there's always a need in some cases so
southeast asian
countries a lot of them
do not have enough talent that have
global experience right let's say
running a global cloud platform
and so if they come here they will help
them
build a team to do that but we won't
that's not the core part of what we do
and certainly we don't do technical
outsourcing we don't help them do the
engineering is what is i don't was that
a question yeah we don't do that but
there's a need
to me the need is not so much about
having large teams because in southeast
asia you can have large teams but it's
about having people with global
experience
that would come from here
are you also looking at u.s companies to
take to asia yes and i'll give you a
case study in detail okay about what
kind of companies sort of is a good
match
so i won't go into too much detail about
this but we have a structured outcome
based success sharing program i'll call
it right
structure it in the sense that we really
walk through companies into various
stages the idea there is just to try to
mitigate risk
when a southeast asian company wants to
enter the us market
even though they already have product
and revenue and they're ready for series
a
but without traction without
partnerships without anything in the us
we don't even know whether they're
competitive whether the business model
needs to be tweaked uh whether the
product features need to be tweaked
because the product market fit
so we walk them through various steps of
assessment and validation for six months
before we even say okay we're gonna now
look for funding for you guys that's the
last step one the third step so we
really go through a structured way of
assessing what the opportunity is
validating it here in the us for six
months getting enough traction that
convinces both of us that there's value
and then finally we help them scale
which is look for funding
outcome based in the sense that we are
really targeting business milestones you
know we don't get to the business
milestone there's no point in in
continuing to work with this company so
we're not a outcome only i mean not just
a hey you know let's do the demo day and
we're you know we're done right we're
just there to actually build traction
when we work with you
um
so some of our southeast asian companies
just to give you an idea of the
companies we work with in malaysia
there's an enterprise workflow software
company there is an enterprise bi
company
joget and data micron in singapore i
mentioned quantity the video
interviewing platform software company a
cloud security company called cloud
cloud and even in brunei there's some
startups that are coming in mobile
education and anonymous messaging
and then the philippines mobile fraud
management so all these companies are
growth stage companies and they're sort
of at the same situation as i mentioned
for uh in just now
um in the us we also so in the u.s what
we do is we look for companies
uh that are also growth stage that have
a potential for the southeast asia
specific market right so southeast asia
as i said infrastructure build out right
on growing middle class number of online
users growing there's a unique set of
opportunities that we try to match us
companies to
especially when we look at in the us now
there's so many seed funded companies
that a lot of them are hitting the
series a crunch
and when they reach series a crunch we
try
to help them
match them up with opportunities in
southeast asia
that includes partners that includes
customers and that includes funding a
lot of which is of course government
subsidized
and i'll give you a specific case study
of what that means so this is a great
win-win in the sense that there are many
us companies that are saying
help me you know either i re-capitalize
in the u.s or i expand and when i expand
i don't know where to go should i go to
china should i go to southeast asia so
these are some of the considerations the
u.s companies are are having so we have
a portfolio of these types of u.s
companies and i'll actually talk about
one case study but in general they cover
info tech like this
to electronics
uh to energy and environment i won't go
through all of these but it's very quite
broad in terms of our portfolio so let
me talk about the case study
and then we'll we'll try to wrap it up
so here is a a us
led technology company
so they have a portfolio of patents 57
patents
they they basically invented
ac leds which is the alternating current
leds typically leds majority of them are
dc powered but they've actually invented
how to do it with ac which means you can
now plug the light directly into the
socket rather than going through a
conversion
so that lowers the cost of the
components and lowers
the the failure rate of the components
and of course allows
more interesting form factors of the
light to be developed right the world is
going led and these guys are saying that
the world will
move back to ac
which is a lot more convenient
they've been they have a small around of
a small round of investment um they've
got a small
product business of their own but what
they're sitting on is a large portfolio
of patents and they're only one of two
holders in the world of these types of
ac led patents
so they've tried to actually
get more investment in the u.s they're
not getting it why because investors
here don't like hardware
okay
they've tried to get acquired but
unfortunately the ac led market has not
grown fast enough
such that an acquirer will say hey i'm
gonna pay x hundred million dollars for
this for these patents
so what we do is we say wait let me help
you
evaluate whether there are
opportunities in asia are there
acquirers in asia or are they joint
venture partners in asia and this is an
active deal that we're working on so
what we've done is we've actually
started matching them up with the sh in
shenzhen in china
of the of the led manufacturers are
actually 70 of the world output of led
comes from shenzhen so we've started
matching them up with joint venture
partners in china
and we've also tried started to do the
same in malaysia malaysia has a pretty
active manufacturing sector 40 of the
gdp output of malaysia is actually
manufacturing sector and so we've tried
to match them up with a bunch of
manufacturers in malaysia as well
so it's a joint venture kind of a model
in a sense that they're going to build a
new operating company
manufacturers that want to have access
to the pets would get
licenses to actually manufacture it for
this particular segment of ac leds in
return they must invest in this joint
venture
five million dollars and above
so we're building up a whole ip holding
company for ac led
investors are actually manufacturers
that want to have exclusive
manufacturing rights and then on top of
that we're getting governments to come
in and start to invest in this whole
entity so it's a deal like this that
sounds very complex but it's just an
example of a pipeline of deals where we
say we find very good
technology from the us
good products good team but they're
struggling they're struggling because
they cannot survive in the us
and we're trying to bring them to asia
using a model which which could work
so this is what we've done with them
uh finally i will just say this i will
summarize by saying here are some of the
opportunities for bridging
southeast asia and the u.s startup
ecosystem
the strategic benefits
of doing so are number one as i said
there's a large green field market
there are business incentives that the
governments are offering everything from
tax holidays
to
subsidizing operating costs to you know
grants matching funds that are available
i.p protection
just because some of the countries in
southeast asia come from a british
colonial background they do inherit some
of these
legal systems so there's a lot better ip
protection compared to other parts of
asia
strategic partnerships what i mean here
is that
because
the individual countries in southeast
asia are smaller
the companies there and the governments
they're a lot more opening to real
strategic partnerships as opposed to
we have such a large domestic market
we can be global players and you guys if
you come in
you're just gonna be
you know a junior partner to us it's not
like that in southeast asia when you go
to southeast asia and you look to build
a partnership these people look to the
us as being a strategic partner and
they're willing to to to to do it it's a
talent hub there's a lot of talent there
and it's a low cost of obviously it's a
very low cost site
not only in terms of manpower is low
cost but advertising is super low cost
one tenth of that in the us
so
ways of doing the bridging i would say
one good way of doing it is really
startups immersion what i mean by that
is
just like startup chile where the
country of chile south america is
getting startups from the u.s to go
there for a couple of months singapore
and malaysia are starting to do that
they're really trying to create
incentives for startups to be co-working
together for a couple of months so that
hopefully they find and build cross
cross-border companies
cross-border networking we just don't
see enough of that if you look at all
the various associations for networking
in silicon valley how many of them
actually have a southeast asian presence
very few if any um
cross-border accelerators we're starting
to see some founder institute is there
bootstrap labs is their plug-in place
there and we are there so we're starting
to see cross-border accelerators
focusing and then investors as well
golden gate elixir capital sovereign
capital seymour ventures are all u.s vcs
that actually now have a site fund in
southeast asia so i think collectively
we do a bunch of these things we should
be able to bridge these ecosystems a lot
more in the future
so that's what i had today
thank you very much for your time
question
we do have some time for questions i ask
you
is um
what kind of a business model are you
working with are you taking an equity
position in the company it's actually
successful success sharing and and um
and an equity model
until we raise our own fund we cannot
invest in it so we syndicate investments
and we get an equity portion of the
business but for the deals commercial
deals that we cut we also get a
revenue share yeah okay so those two
models success
commission and equity based okay great
how did you get into this
from being a venture on you know on your
own serial entrepreneur and so forth um
about seven years ago
i started working with startups
to help them do business development
companies that are trying to get into
the us from europe or from asia
and then i joined as a mentor in plug
and play and i really saw how a very
large scalable accelerator works and
then founder institute as well both of
these have over a thousand companies
already under their umbrella more than a
thousand actually
so i saw wow these guys really
are trying to innovate a business model
around acceleration and that's why i
wanted to try and do it myself in this
case i chose southeast asia because
there's just not enough attention i
think i feel to that region everybody's
focused on china or india
but southeast asia still has a lot of
greenfield opportunity okay and the next
question is to what extent do you really
have to
look at southeast asia as something
where you have to do it country by
country but you really need to go to all
in order to have a sufficient market i
mean we haven't talked much about
thailand we haven't talked much about
vietnam right right you know and those
are big markets yeah yeah uh you know 90
million people in vietnam that's right
and they're one of these places that has
a 90
you know uh penetration rate for cell
phones right right so uh do you really
think through and say okay we'll start
in singapore because
you know done in bradstreet the ease of
doing business index i always show up
number one or number two is the place
where it's easiest to do business in the
whole world yeah and so that's a great
place to start but then you've got to
have a strategy is a question in the
context of a u.s company going there or
integral ventures meaning us or is it in
the context of a asian company i'm
thinking of either a u.s company startup
that would want to go into southeast
asia or possibly an asia company
right right but not not tgv itself
um
you know i would say that if you're an
american company uh
you would want to go to either singapore
because you want to have a place which
is the hub right and it's a hub for all
these things i mentioned the networking
the vcs are there the accelerators are
there the government is very very
supportive
if you want to have a lower cost place
then you will go to malaysia right it
has a fourth of the cost of singapore
basically
but
these other places once you establish an
initial presence in either singapore or
malaysia then you absolutely want to go
after the big markets and usually you do
that the next one will be indonesia yeah
before they go into vietnam right or the
philippines
but
in terms of whether they're all one at a
time unfortunately as i said due to
fragmentation
in reality it's still one at a time
right oh let's say you sell into
consumer market in indonesia uh on the
consumer mobile market in indonesia well
guess what you still have to go through
telcom sell because they are the ones
that has the marketing dollars to get
access to that group yeah and so you
have to find your way into telecom cell
right the tried and true way
there is something called an asean
economic community that's being built
launched next year in 2015 it's
basically an economic grouping of the 10
countries
although it'll be launched next year a
lot of people believe that it's going to
take many more years beyond that to
really have effect in terms of you know
consolidated legal systems and and free
flow of jobs and stuff like that but it
will help the european community
starting what 1957 or something
and unification eu unification happened
in 92 or something like that yeah and
finally they get a common currency in
2000. exactly yeah it does take a lot so
the reality is still it's still the
fragmentation problem right but in terms
of where you would start first you would
start in places which has the most
the friendliest to set up and do
business
and then it does offer you the ability
to then get into the other markets if
you went to indonesia first for example
in jakarta
it will still be a bit of the wild west
right you know you'd have to talk to
five different government agencies to
find out whether you have a license to
do this or not right whereas in
singapore it's like you know who to go
to
right yeah yeah okay let's open the
floor
yes how do you
evaluate the language that's like the
malaysian language and the machine
language are kind of similar so that can
be looked at
together this kind of thing yeah it's a
good point uh bahasa indonesia and
bahasa malayu from malaysia are very
similar
right so there's an advantage therefore
if you set up shop in malay malaysia
you have a ready pool of malay speakers
that could easily converse with
indonesians right so there is that
benefit right
you know 200 plus million people in
indonesia and and malaysia with 28
million so there's some benefit if you
do it that way but otherwise language
wise you know thai is very different
from vietnamese which is very different
from filipino
there are countries like the philippines
malaysia singapore where english is
widely spoken so that helps there is a
talent pool of english speakers that are
in these three large countries
in indonesia english is probably less
they're less capable there right but
otherwise english is okay in three other
countries and then malay in two but
everything else is quite fragmented
language-wise
okay you haven't really touched on
vietnam it has some of the most um
educated engineers and some of the
biggest startups in the whole southeast
asia what are your thoughts as to its
future yeah i i we have not been in
vietnam as yet
that's why i didn't cover it and it's
also
uh not the largest not the most
developed from an ecosystem standpoint
uh certainly you know hopefully we want
to focus there next time but we haven't
focused on that so i've got a couple of
comments on that because we've featured
vietnam several times in our spring
entrepreneurship series
and one of the things that stands out to
me was a person who said that
you have to
win in the market there you can't go in
and expect to survive as number two
it's a very much an all or nothing
market in vietnam
certain areas are more subject to
corruption
and so you have to be careful about that
especially as an american business if
you get involved in corruption you can
be put into jail here
right for
bribing somebody in a different country
uh
so
vietnam is difficult there's a real
active
early adopter group but they tend to be
doing things
not exactly at bottom of the pyramid but
kind of close to bottom of the pyramid
there's an awful lot of internet use but
it's mostly from internet cafes still
so uh it's an interesting place
but i noticed that you didn't mention
vietnam yeah and i think that in terms
of a southeast asia strategy you develop
the places where you can develop
you keep increasing your own resources
and that makes it easier in the next the
more difficult markets
yeah
hey peter
in one of your charts on the exits there
was a big pool that
was
exiting in hong kong or related to hong
kong so is that um
companies going into china through hong
kong or is it just china exits that use
hong kong protection yeah i didn't focus
on the hong kong piece that was the
largest
the total acquisition is the largest out
of hong kong
i didn't go into that just because it's
outside of southeast asia but i can
point you to the report and you can go
into detail as to what is the nature of
those deals
yeah
okay
good can you describe a kind of a
typical entrepreneur in southeast asia
and what have you found are maybe their
biggest misunderstandings about startups
or being entrepreneurs
yeah you know they're still um you know
like most asians right uh
uh they're very conservative um
parents
do not encourage people to take risks
out of college right and there's still a
lot of stigma of failure
in places like singapore where there's a
lot more development of the ecosystem
there's now
several waves of entrepreneurs that have
actually been educated and
and given incentives and and all that
so the typical and so the typical
entrepreneur is basically you know
people in their uh 20s or 30s that are
out you know doing their their first
startup
uh
they're generally less obviously less
experienced at doing this compared to
you know
here they're they're people that try it
typically five to eight times right
easily
over there they're trying it for the
first time so there are a lot of
first-time mistakes that they're they're
good they're going to make
so i've heard investors going in there
and saying that um
that when they
and these people have have investment
experience here and and in southeast
asia they basically are coming across
many many teams that are first-time
entrepreneurs right compared to here
where there's still some repeat
entrepreneurs right and so they make a
lot of first-time mistakes
generally they
are willing to take the risk
they lament the fact that when their
time for growth stage and they're
looking for growth stage funding there's
still a serious a gap in southeast asia
but the gap there is for a different
reason the gap exists here just because
of series a ebc is being disrupted by
the seed investors right and they're
therefore moving downstream there like
that seriously investment just never
existed
right in large numbers so it's it's a
gap and so the startups lament the fact
that these vcs don't exist when it's
time for them to to get investment but
now you know there's some
m a that they can point to to show that
hey you know over the last six years a
certain number of m a's have happened
although the valuations are still low
but at least there's some success
stories and so then the cycle starts to
repeat you now have repeat entrepreneurs
have been successful through the early
earlier exits that are now vcs
that are now starting their second or
third venture
so it's starting to turn right uh but
but that's the nature of the ecosystem
right now so would you say that the
entrepreneurs are on average about the
same age as they are here a little older
a little younger
younger i would say younger okay yeah
okay a lot of it is uh because all of
the successes and the opportunities are
in the online and mobile space
where it's very low cost anybody can get
it going right it's unlike here where
there's a lot of enterprise
opportunities yeah and which require a
lot more veterans that run those kinds
of companies security you know yeah
supply chain you don't think of a b2b
idea like you've got some bee experience
yeah right exactly exactly
okay i saw your hand next
how uh how do you see the uh
into which asc
came from this company
that's right but uh he did a specific
market which is going to be integrated
very fast
with regard to payments in particular or
e-commerce or something right yeah
you know i would say that uh
surprisingly philippines has one of the
most
developed mobile payments markets in the
region if not the world just because of
the fact that a lot of people that are
unbanked and mobile adoption has been so
early there in the philippines and they
have a larger domestic population close
to 100 million so they've innovated like
crazy and they've had mobile payments
for the last 10 years i think or more
and you know here we're struggling with
apple pay right and and whatever
currency okay being hacked you know so
these guys have innovated like crazy so
i think if any kind of integration
happens it'll be by the leading
countries like that in the payment space
in the philippines or the more developed
countries like singapore where you know
the infrastructure and the regulatory
framework is really there for them to to
drive this type of integration but but
payment integration across the region is
still a big opportunity because it just
doesn't you know doesn't work in other
countries like thailand and indonesia
and others
okay i saw a hand over here go ahead yes
here i have a question um so malaysia um
general area do you see a lot of um
interest or development in new areas
like wearable electronics or internet of
things stuff
that kind of hardware stuff
yeah so we are actually working to try
to get a consortium of companies in
malaysia interested in
um sort of the hardware accelerator
model like you see starting here
and in china
you know at the government level i would
say that despite the fact that in the
electronics industry in malaysia as i
said represents 40 of the output of the
malaysia
however
they're usually just supply chain to the
multinationals the intels and the amd's
and all these other guys that are in the
region
so
they do want to get ahead of the curve
in front of wearables and iot and all
that stuff
but uh it's it's typical thing right
when you run a big factory and someone
says here's a hardware accelerator model
and i'm going to give you a whole bunch
of startups and all these spaces they'll
say so what's the volume projection for
next year
right
you know and so
therefore when we're trying to do a deal
like the ac led joint venture that i
just mentioned as a case study
we have to get the government involved
because in that country that we have to
sell it as hey malaysia how would you
like to own an ip pool right that gives
you that allows all malaysian
manufacturers to have a control of the
ecosystem as it evolves globally and not
be a
fast follower to china let alone
complete follower to the us and paying
out all your technology license fees to
some foreign exactly yeah and so the
governments because we have access to
some of these uh
decision makers in the various
government agencies that i mentioned
they will listen they will take the
meeting and when we come to them and say
hey we are silicon valley accelerator we
have access to a portfolio of prop of ip
how would you like to and we have to
sell them the whole strategy right you
are going to be able to
create a few global players in the in
the led space how would you like to do
that rather than just you know throw a
couple of billion dollars at some
companies that continue to manufacture
for other people
so it's that kind of positioning and i
would say opportunity still exists
so that kind of leads me to a question
and that is the two of the old you know
sort of workhorses for uh
southeast asia
services like call center services or
other i.t services and also contract
manufacturing right did not enter into
your presentation right right are you
finding that those industries have
generated people with an interest in
entrepreneurship or is it really a new
set of people
um
it it it is a new set of people right i
mean country manufacturing in malaysia
has been around for a while i mean
intel's been there for 40 plus years so
the ecosystem that supports it has been
around
that long distance that's right really
and outsourcing has been a focus by by
mdec for the last 10 15 years so you
know it is already established so when i
talk about startups ecosystem the new
stuff that's all the
stuff that's different from these two
it's different from services it's
different from contract manufacturing it
is about about online and mobile and
social and all of these other and
hardware right there's an interest in
hardware too um
it's just that from uh
from an ecosystem perspective just that
just elaborate a little bit more on
let's let's say you know is iot and
wearables is that going to be a big
thing in malaysia
we have to work extra hard at building a
business case to do it
uh unlike let's say taiwan or china
where you know the ecosystem is big
enough right there is interest to do
that so they can invest small parts of
money and say hey let's invest in this
new growth area whereas in malaysia it's
not big enough that they can invest
right they're still following where the
supply chain is going
like you said they're
looking at the global market that's the
size of the local market right yeah yeah
that's right
i saw your name yeah yeah i'm just
curious uh as far as little thought
you're answering this question about uh
working with governments and helping
people find partners you sort of follow
like the plug-and-play model where they
like work with edb you can bring people
here and then use them as a
sort of underground assistance to set up
a
an underground incubator or to develop
business on the ground in singapore or
region we um
yeah we're trying to do that i will say
that you know in the in the country so
we've been actively engaging with
singapore malaysia brunei philippines
right i didn't mention brunei in
philippines just because i'm out of time
uh but um
every uh every startup ecosystem is at a
different stage singapore is is advanced
enough that they know who to work with
right and if they come they have a very
specific requirement and if you meet
that requirement then they're their
partner i mean their government's
partner right malaysia is still evolving
and so they're open to them
outsourcing a whole chunk of their
startup development bridging you know
work to you right brunei is like so
small
right that they're just starting to
figure out and they're doing wholesale
outsourcing end-to-end of the of startup
ecosystem build up which we're helping
them with so it varies
there is no cookie cutter kind of a
model uh we're small enough and boutique
enough that we can try to pick and
choose what are the what other deals we
do compared to a plug-and-play which is
really about scale
right you know i won't go into detail
about the model but the model is all hey
we've got the building 500 companies are
going to be in there mr government you
want to come you know here's the
sponsorship package
right yeah right so i this reminds me of
a company that i was advising and
suddenly they got an offer from
someone in brunei right okay very high
up who was going to
financing financing into the company but
it was going to be through islamic
financing okay you know models right
right and finding an expert who could go
through delusions the
all the conditions and make sure it was
a good deal or not was really hard
in brunei you mean well the the proposal
came from brunei the company itself was
in japan oh okay and uh it was
fascinating because finding somebody who
understood islamic financing was right
practically non-existent well there's a
lot of there's a lot of knowledge there
in malaysia actually malaysia is one of
the countries that led the creation of
islamic financing and so that's why
they're growing the space in the middle
east and brunei as well you know you
mentioned brunei i mean we helped some
of the companies that are in our program
are from brunei
brunei of course is just like dubai
they're trying to diversify away from
oil right they know oil is going to run
out or us is going to outproduce them or
something and so they needed to
diversify and attack so they built an
incubator partners partnering with
singapore actually to build an incubator
and they need people like us to help do
that bridging with silicon valley
and it's very interesting because when
we were there in june
they were about to pass sharia law i
don't know whether you know what sharia
law israel is really a more stricter
version of islamic
legal system within brunei and you know
every you know people within the tech
community in a small tech community
bruno are panicking and saying oh no now
people won't invest in us anymore
because we follow sharia law and brunei
and i told them that there are a lot of
other reasons why u.s companies won't
invest in youth don't worry about sharia
law
that's the least thing you should worry
about
you know
you worry about market traction
so to the limits of my understanding in
islamic financing you cannot charge
interest because that's considered usury
in islam
so what happens is you have all of these
procedures for
something that kind of looks like an
equity warrant yeah that
is yet guaranteed for return and so you
know the valuation of the investment and
so forth
you need somebody who's really expert in
that right
um yeah
question
can you talk people about the payment
mobile payment in like philippine and uh
singapore are they similar to apple pay
this kind of thing
um
yeah probably will have maybe you can do
that during the networking session uh we
did a project with a smart telecom which
is the number one mobile operator in the
philippines with over
90 million subscribers
and they're one of the innovators right
in mobile payments
they've been able to use their phone and
their phone number
to load up credits from their real bank
accounts and do payments for the last 10
plus years right
and of course they've started to now
expand into nfc and other technologies
that enable more seamless payments right
the project we work with them on is
mobile fraud management uh mobile fraud
is actually very big uh in
fraud anyway it's very big in asia in
fact the biggest market for fraud is the
us as we know but
in asia is very big too so they had a
solution where
they could you could connect up all your
debit credit type accounts into your
phone number
and and set various thresholds on all of
these accounts like amount transacted
time of transaction locality or
transaction and venue of transaction
such that when these thresholds are
exceeded you get an alert on your phone
and then you have to approve it so it's
part of the payment
cycle right you have to approve it
before that debit or credit or whatever
transaction can happen
and so they pioneered that just because
they've done so much mobile payment on
phones that they realize that now this
capability is
because of the growing growth of fraud
is happening but we can talk a little
bit more offline and we can tell you a
little bit about that so
most of the regional
business development in southeast asia
do you think that will carry it that
maybe plus the u.s the reason i'm asking
is do you think the general slowdown of
gdp in china is going to negatively
impact
southeast asia business opportunities a
lot
uh if you talk about the traditional
businesses like contract manufacturing
outsourcing all that stuff that feeds
into china as well of course i would get
impacted right um
if you talk about uh i mean there's
another dynamic there that
that perhaps are starting to see and
this this came from a japanese
investor so there are a lot of i don't
know whether you remember from the
slides but there are a couple of new
japanese vcs that are now in southeast
asia and so we asked one of them
why why are you interested in southeast
asia so beyond the usual green field and
all of that yeah his answer was
interesting i'm pivoting away from china
so i said why are you pivoting away from
china he said well it's slowing down and
then number two there are now geopolitic
political pressures between china and
japan yeah and so it says because of
that a lot of the things that we try to
do are much much harder when we try to
do it with china so we have to go back
to southeast asia the japanese were in
southeast asia if you remember back in
the 70s or 80s big time right the asian
tigers were born just because japan
and later on korea and others started
taiwan started moving some of the
manufacturing to southeast asia which is
a lot more lower cost now the cycle is
repeated but now in the online space you
know these vcs are there to invest in
all those green field opportunities i
showed you on that eye chart because
they say well
you know south asia is where japan was
you know 15 years ago so i can make bets
as to which segment is going to grow
next and so that's why he's investing
that's so cool
exactly yeah so that this is why it's a
repeat right so that's why the japanese
are there and so this pivot away from
china is a theme that i'm seeing uh i
don't know whether you're seeing some of
the press right well what the countries
will say is china plus one that was
vietnam's big push right
don't just look at china but look at us
too uh and right so you know i do think
whether it's a pivot or whether it's an
expansion to hedge risk yeah you know
you're seeing both
and i think the general point for all
business everywhere is that you cannot
assume that the current distribution of
economic power is a stable thing
yeah you know it's going to be changing
and so watching what happens in this
area as more money flows into it is
really important yeah yeah yeah i think
the um you know one of the topics that
you wanted to cover in our talk was
about the rise of the global startup and
where does the southeast asia players
stand
as i mentioned right
there is enough help from certain
ecosystems to to to have a large pool of
early stage companies when they get the
growth stage
they struggle with the three strategic
options that i mentioned do they become
an american company
do they go to china
or do they become just a regional player
and get bought out yeah and those are
the three things that they struggle with
a lot of them can't make it past that
chasm
right just because they're like you know
i can't get the funding and i didn't
know which strategy option to take when
i spend my time doing one it fails and
then they're out of time
but on the other hand in a sense that's
three options a lot of people only see
two of those three period in other
places right
yeah so i think that you know seeing
more options is a good thing
so the so other places they lose the
china option is that your no they lose
the southeast asia option right right
right
china that's a good point in in
southeast asia most of the m a has
happened just because they've stayed as
a regional player they've got market
share in indonesia in malaysia boom they
got brought up by groupon
right it's a sub 50 million exit but hey
you know
five million went into it so
good are you seeing any uh human
resources shortages
for this kind of thing are you so a lot
of entrepreneurs are first-time
entrepreneurs yes what about the people
who come to work in the companies
are they able to get the technical
people they need are they able to
you know i i have not heard about
you know a shortage in
engineering like like like you see here
um probably ux people and design people
there's a shortage of quality people
there
as i said you know chief architect kind
of roles people with global experience
running global platforms you get much
fewer of those
um
so that's where they would
we are encouraging some of these
southeast asian companies to
to partner with professionals here in
the valley to fill those gaps right
people that have ux experience people
that have growth hacking experience
people that have these types of um uh
right you know running large platforms
types experience and
you know co-founders are very difficult
you anybody has started a company that
tries to find a co-founder to do it well
we'll live through that it's very hard
to find co-founders it's almost like
it's harder than getting married but you
know
but but just imagine if you are a
southeast asian company and you're a
silicon valley company or professional
like all of us here and you're trying to
figure out hey should i do a
cross-border company what does that mean
right can we make this global right
do we just become a china player which
is big enough by the way very big in it
enough in and of itself right
so
you know the telling gaps are because of
these things right yeah design
uh architecting okay
by the way but the cost of the rest of
the team is super low i mean yeah like i
said advertising costs on facebook and
youtube are 1 10 in asia compared to
what they are in the us
the cost of talent of hiring people in
malaysia is
40 cheaper than singapore right which is
very expensive so and then i haven't
mentioned vietnam where they're much
cheaper in philippines which is even
cheaper
right so
english educated i mean english-speaking
you know workers right
okay well let's
move our session offline now to the
networking and uh please join me winston
thanks for a great session that was
really informative
thanks for having me
you